psycho babble and we're back with conch
loose and we're gonna get to that
conclusion we're gonna conclude this
[ __ ] I hand the shet working out great
the key word off let that fight there we
go okay let's see here
last I saw was this okay let's go let's
go you at the end what what the [ __ ] I
got [ __ ] stuck that [ __ ] is that
hello babies Oh [ __ ] quarter
oh wait an apartment you know tonight
strange weather has been something
mudslide non-dairy trees should be
diesel in the utility room you get just
quarter oh [ __ ] yeah baby make tons of
calls with dispatch
hey is my
ooh okay I can't take that thank you
very much thank you very much lives in
here
nothing's in here nothing my hands
nothing my hands let's see a shuttle
[ __ ] TVs where's the [ __ ] is utility
room like call hum is there points
anymore I don't think a new one picks up
anymore no no one's picking up [ __ ]
horse [ __ ] if you ask me are you around
the building I can't don't let you on
the grass I guess it kind of does no it
doesn't it doesn't okay
where's each OT room nothing over here
means keep going I guess right we're
over Forest Service it's right here oh
[ __ ] this does not look healthy okay let
me make sure everyone's safe
okay I mean make sure everyone's safe
okay over there
crash school bus tours at you damage the
inside
guess that's just the map telling me
don't [ __ ] go there alright can I get
over here yeah over here
that's [ __ ] dark I can dark out here
anything [ __ ] over here so I can
target [ __ ]
whoa holy [ __ ] I suppose to be up here
[ __ ] over there
just some fog
yeah some fire sure you look cool all
[ __ ] up
i touching that and i'm getting sick no
not getting sick whoa what so I just
like loaded you Teddy room okay
apparently the oil here [ __ ] [ __ ] on
the ground so let's [ __ ] in on the lower
place Sarah chambers anyone finds this
I'm trapped in the bathroom I walked
home through a part of school because
the nice day out I had to go to the
bathroom what every minute out door
won't open there's a creepy lady in the
last all she's really long hair and
she's pulling it out throwing on the
floor she last all very not creepy lady
in there Darren Shan here okay
hey fern I get that fern well let me
walk over there doors locked
use the utility room kick the [ __ ] is
this he's all there the Terri do is
leave the plow what blah fill the tank
with diesel pump bleep screw or located
near the fuel filter on the oil engine
and the primer clean it ten minutes
tight in it okay
seems explained it self-explanatory the
door is unlocked
who's that lady in here the [ __ ] stole
the [ __ ] toilets guess I can't check
trash cans anymore what is this
dead end tree fell okay so I got to get
back to that that uh and that plow not
like a truck truck truck
you know pushy truck okay um yeah find
out where the hell that is
I think is alway back here no see like
skips me it definitely can map ending
knocks chewing on some bones you know
that mind her don't mind her you know
she's just doing her own thing she's
just doing her own thing don't you go
boo boo okay let's see here that's oh my
god that's so tragic so tragic they were
so young okay come on come on all right
yeah where are you where are you okay
that was the best whole quarter there's
no one there I think there's like I can
find it take off the robe I think
there's skid marks there's not a [ __ ]
Terrace
yeah hiragana Erica
and get ki see me going okay yeah I see
this screw the [ __ ] do I get the key era
tints are fuel no that's what I'm gonna
get here [ __ ] do I get the key then
whiplash to look down the blouse to
start now okay how do I [ __ ] start it
and I start this bench so I don't need a
canteen where was it the entrance and
anything no no that's where I got in
here
thank miss opinion like a toilet I think
my probably one of the taught a [ __ ]
key in it so Matt that was it that
that's the case [ __ ] that thing is
dying see here see here any more keys in
here
Ches please
mmm you say if I guess yes
saving say even grace saving grace again
I say here
I'm on school bus so [ __ ] up we don't
get off the road though there's a lot of
shout there but that's scary I know he's
gonna want you to run away stop me
because I think [ __ ] my [ __ ]
keywords I let's see here
then I'm it and this would be load again
so right here anything no let you walk
over there okay just switched me over
okay utility room it's gotta be [ __ ]
here
gotta be here if it's not it's like what
the [ __ ] that [ __ ] is on the ground oh
my god
yep cuz where she was pulling her
[ __ ] hair out Jays is a [ __ ]
[ __ ] angry ha hit you see - [ __ ]
burrito and anger put one in front of me
I'm straight okay stretch
you know it air isn't much of a question
like I would eat it Jesus a lot of
walking in this game but you know it's
Frank so you know I liked it we go on
watch sometimes
okay where was it now I gotta keep going
for a while nothing's chumming that
bound damn your bike [ __ ] here that
shot you say he's a she's a pro you know
like some doves are frozen
some are him burrows but she's a she's a
pro for sure her again use blocking whoa
this is really [ __ ] weird whoa this
is weird I'm [ __ ] driving dingoes
this way
holy [ __ ] you [ __ ] okay this way I'll
follow this yellow line
you know don't drink and drive guys okay
the eora to see how hard it is to upward
heavy machinery so why make it harder
you know what the road [ __ ] turn or
something
can't see [ __ ] [ __ ] here we go
okay here's the load where's the tree
there we go
oh hell what is it say welcome to hell
Jesus I thought they weren't good OVA oh
no no they were now here's the whole
timer if I can step in Cordova okay
you're better I mean Kimmie's whole
[ __ ] way
I don't know when you come this much
it's like you nobody will escape to play
scariest [ __ ] but also like you've gone
through a lot so I like [ __ ] at the end
I don't know where the [ __ ] I'm going
gets down here yeah okay I give you that
yeah this place [ __ ] sucks really
I need like a homeowner's association or
something okay loading screen I please
keep out okay where else do I go
it's [ __ ] closed it's closed like
where do I go says slow oh can I just go
around yeah
and King that same station okay like
it's tough here but me save real quick
[ __ ] in trying to [ __ ] it oh that's
that the [ __ ] water
okay
who knows my dog sniffing you better at
stuff the ground too much is it I
[ __ ] her rock a walnut
enter the axe I got a moonstone this is
getting weird
top five Danny and I'm unsound for if
you need a moonstone you're probably
doing something you shouldn't do Jade
energetic I knew it what do you intend
Stefan hey very sad and she's alert he
walked over time
okay path closer to landslide it's
interesting so he's got a cleft a
[ __ ] moon gems anytime I have to
click moon reminds you of like when I
was in the library younger and plain was
weird like dolphin friendly games
briefcase
three Jim and his third walnut then I'm
gonna get a [ __ ] therapy ball not any
[ __ ] one that's right here me past a
walnut and didn't even know is along
that you get one that over here right
yeah wait did I come this way yeah I
came each way okay no for a walnut
before I go on off on the [ __ ] track
you see okay I went that way I've done
this way already
I don't think I have any quarters yeah
what is this a no quarter
maybe we can only call her like wall
inhale we check
[ __ ]
see how come on me I'm trained okay let
me check for Wallner over here oh yeah
on that
he's a kid okay let me guess I'm gonna
go and crack up on the one I get a gem
throw it in the grape gazing at a king
okay you say so I think it's a great
over here yeah
cabin kings okay it's like [ __ ]
clockwork it's that clockwork she's cute
she's really cute now cat see here
yeah this way hopefully work to end
Noteboom caretaker who landslide first
close however you need take the boat
into town if there's an britain's that
remember the boat on the right goes
further into hell the boat and left goes
back to Cordova [ __ ] that on leaving
that lirlean do that all there is
at worst
strange noise outside oh my god it is
good in the-- someone's coming
[ __ ] I think I'll be more skater I can
tell what the [ __ ] I was like a sexy
granny CCTV footage that where is it
going
nobody knows ok
plants i this may be a little but you're
gonna need yours I got the worst let's
go baby let's end this
there we go here we go let's out hurry
up right this [ __ ]
Oh a quarter there
look there's the cover quarters
there's dollar right the hell you Lena
oh [ __ ]
calm boy [ __ ] hey don't eat that [ __ ]
alright um you're welcome
hey did get it delete that back should I
need this back Jesus
the dog is like I was any coming for a
story I came here for a free ride and
now I'm kind of regretting it with the
story
I think yo he's like sang on sat the
[ __ ] dog and I was like trying to take
a nap
left
Oh
how is that do you want me to find you
Carolyn
that she has beautifully Amy Adams
that's as I'm talking about John tomaron
good game good game
yeah gentleman they're really good at
that I first came out really good for
your first game old again and anyways
tell our time Adam okay close that's
that conclusion I've come close alright
guys thanks for watching y'all and I
guess we'll see you around
please browse